hi everybody good evening first of all
Thank You Dalia for organizing this
great Meetup it's the first ever Marine
data emitter so it's exciting the
industry is quite small and apparently
everyone knows each other so it's a
pretty cool to see I will start by
saying some things first of all thank
you at a meal our system engineer at the
Oak III for helping me achieving a one
of my dreams
second of all Thank You Dalia and Google
campus and windward for sponsoring all
of this and third and last but not least
thank you both my parents they just
landed today from Australia and they
just came here
they're super tired I can see that but
they're sitting here so thank you mom
and dad
my name is doe I'm a co-founder and a
CTO of a newly founded startup called
Orca a I am a little bit about what
we're gonna talk about today so setting
sails towards autonomous ships
interesting subject a little bit about
Orca we secured our first a refinance
round of 2.5 million dollars in July so
it's not a long time ago
it was founded by me and one of my best
friends from the Israeli Navy
we'll both naval instructors in Haifa
and the team a one of them is here but
the team consists of a arnd mainly a
software engineers algorithm engineer
and a system engineer and we're sitting
in a Rothschild in it Tel Aviv and then
we are growing so we're being be up
later maybe so the oceans are huge right
we don't see things like that happen
every day there's a lot of space to sail
all around the ocean yeah it even
mentioned in his a lecture did you see
how many ships were near Italy so maybe
there are a lot of ships at sea and
maybe things like that actually happen
this is a picture of an Norwegian
worship that color
with commercial ship need no way and the
ship was lost and it cost four hundred
million dollars worship the entire 140
people of the crew got evacuated because
someone didn't pay attention to what's
going on outside
oops and why is it happening usually
because you need to be an expert at
sailing at sea it's not something that
everywhere everyone can do like really
good without any expertise so you need
to be able to operate different sensors
like radar like a is this is there a is
binoculars which is hard to operate all
right so let's return to today we're
2019 let's talk about some buzz words
because everyone loves buzz words Donna
most cars happening right in hell celeea
in tel-aviv Donna most trucks roaming
the entire Road in the United States
autonomous drones mapping construction
sites autonomous everything why not
autonomous ships but it's quite hard
because the marine domain even though
it's one of the most ancient I would say
domains in the world people have been
shipping goods since the dawn of time
it's one of the oldest in the world it's
actually a key to some interesting
concept that we all know and love today
like insurance companies they started
for the marine domain a supply chain
something that's very interesting for
all of us but it's also started over
there and many other interesting
concepts like the commercial flight
domain captain cockpit deck it's all
from ships and the problem is that there
are almost no standards in the field and
why why is that when you go up on a
commercial plane nowadays you know it's
gonna be an Airbus or a Boeing right in
ships it's not quite the same why is
that historically there are many much
more ship
yards throughout the world the Chinese
are actually building ships very
differently from the finish and every
ship transfers different goods in
different locations of the world so a
ship that's designed to sail the Baltic
Sea near icebergs is not suitable for
sailing in the Caribbean Sea where the
humidity is like fun and the latest
technology achievements in this field
due to the lack of standards because
it's hard to put new software new
technology in a generic way on ships
means that the latest technology jumps
were actually the radar the AIS the GPS
and the latest update you can go out
without paper maps onboard ships
it is really recent it's really
technological advantage so um
Orca inspired by the autonomous domain
autonomous cars domain and we actually
aim to develop intelligent collision
avoidance system based on deep learning
because deep learning is the thing route
right we would love also to alert on
possibly dangerous situation and maybe
even provide early a nice recommendation
that the captain itself would have think
of but we'll talk about autonomous ships
later because no one's taking autonomous
ships now they're not ready when you go
out to a shipping company and say hey
I'll make you ship autonomous without
anyone on board he's like yeah no I have
7,000 cars on my ship no it's gonna be
sailing with people on it no don't worry
so um why why deep learning at all right
so people try to do situational
awareness using classical computer
vision methods but like Vicky told
earlier the number of variables is just
too high you cannot converge on a simple
pattern of rules
to catch all the edge cases in the
marine domain and why is that because
the variability is just too high too
many edge cases so deep learning for the
rescue it's great for generalization
feed it data it will solve everything
especially a real-world problem so one
nice example that I always love to show
is we clearly all of us can see that
this this is a boat right yeah pretty
easy to see yeah it has its own like
little must here the bridge but this is
also about right what about this are
they looking the same can we build a
rule-based
algorithm to identify the difference
between these and concorda these two are
ships what about this one this guy this
a ship this looks like a ship but no
it's actually a lighthouse that's
connected to ground right so maybe try
to write a classical algorithm that
looks for masts and contours and I don't
know what not gonna work sorry guys what
about other challenges like a horizon
detection right we wanna maybe a
calculate distance to other objects it's
a nice reference point what is the
horizon in this image is this this one
clearly right but maybe this one as well
what is arisin is it the difference in
the colors like change of colors this is
a bad example to to run your horizon
detection algorithm on as well as here
this is pitch-black darkness almost you
can almost see nothing think of the
noise from the sensor it's a hard case
icebergs the guys at the Titanic did a
great job of identifying icebergs but it
was a bit too late and icebergs actually
a very interesting because no iceberg
look alike they are all DIF different
but maybe we can look on count how many
white pixels are inside the iceberg so
here oh I know twenty thousand pixels
thirty thousand how many here no five
thousand is it still an iceberg for us
it's it's trivial right it's easy but
for machines is harder so deep learning
for the rescue no problem at all just
collect a lot of data how do you do that
let's look at public datasets Microsoft
Co Co the largest data set in the world
18 million images three thousand boat
images most of them are not even boats
sorry yeah kayaks okay so let's go on a
ship it's not that easy no one just hey
guys come over to my ship put your
camera's here no problem at all and just
look outside it what my crew is doing
yeah you can tell you all about how many
people that ships want to know what
their activity is um okay so we got up
on a ship how do you build it data
collection platform and how much data
are you actually generating using this
method so we went on a ship me Anatomy
over here a system engineer he's gonna
be the star of this presentation because
someone had to take all the pictures and
someone was the star so we got up on a
huge car carrier and this is tamir and
someone's taking his luggage and they
put a stamp of ship on my passport which
is pretty cool and this is the ship we
went on it's a 190 meter long car
carrier and we build our external data
collection platform using let's see bet
in English I don't know how to say and
putting a mat back I stamp on the system
and building a t-shape using security
cameras that we bought in Alibaba yeah
one important rule don't send out ten
thousand dollars of electronic equipment
in a cardboard box that Emil found in
the strip and this is what happened to
us a export issue we broke our PCI
Express in the very strong deep learning
a machine
but and the fan also broke but we here
we still had a lot of smiles and we
actually built our interior unit strong
GPU touchscreen all the best and latest
of technologies ate some fish soup
it was delicious just kidding I got sick
on board and I I had like fluid like
fever like 40 degrees and now we start
to collect data it's great right no yeah
most of the data actually looks like
this I mean five percent is actually
meaningful and the rest is just sea and
sky nothing to see here
great okay so we have a problem and the
problem is that the marine show I'll
explain the problem slowly for everyone
to understand so let's say that the
marine domain actually changes once
every 10 minutes okay every 10 minutes
the Sun moves a little bit in the sky
the wind change something interesting
might have happened so let's say that
every 10 minutes we take a snapshot of
the world collect data from all the
sensors of the ship and collect all the
images that that are there because
nothing changes really so this generates
roughly 20 gigabyte of data per month
out of that only 5% has any meaning so
you get you fly to Spain on three
different flights you install a system
on a ship you go on sailing for four
days connect everything it the office
you sit in Tel Aviv you see all the data
comes in and out of it just maybe one
one gigabyte of meaningful data that's
actually good for your system that that
actually is suitable for learning that's
a lot of overhead and that's actually a
lot of garbage data just just for that
so another problem that we have onboard
ship is that its sales at sea right so
how do you send frames from France to
will I know a server in maybe in Paris
right you could use satellite
communication which costs billions for
10 kilobytes and you can use a 4G
communication like our small phones
right so we did just that we bought a
sim international theme we put a dongle
start collecting data but we figured out
that out of the whole sale all the
voyage the actual time of connectivity
using 4G reception in show is very very
little especially in ships that are
doing like cross ocean sales right and
along the way you see a lot of stuff
other than that if we understand that
the connectivity is very short we need
to upload the most meaningful data first
to a service so you can continue
training or deep learning algorithms
right so now we we tackle the question
of what is important let's see is
everything important is nothing
important every time someone touches the
wheel is that important I don't know so
we figured out put some logic in it ask
some questions hey man what is dangerous
and he said yeah if I need to intervene
if I have a lot of ships near me and if
I almost collided with someone that's
meaningful and interesting and we said
ok this is important so let's try to
tackle that code a lot of people here
are from the marine domain which is
great a little bit of code just simple
example of how to create adaptive
framerate saving algorithm very simple
idea so let's say you have an object
detection algorithm that detects other
ships at sea and it works pretty good
let's say that we all the time run this
algorithm and search for objects once we
detected an object let's check out its
speed because it moves a long time so
let's say you you figure out the
threshold for the speed
say if this speed of the object is I
don't know above threshold we'll start
collecting and aggregating data every
second let's let take a lot of snapshots
it's fast it's moving fast it's changing
in the environment it's getting larger
it has a trail something interesting
change in the environment all right
and what happened if the if the vessel
is slow maybe we'll just collect every
like five times a minute this I think
it's a good good enough the world
doesn't change a lot let's see and other
than that maybe we'll still collect
every 10 minutes so guys this is
actually one of the part of our
algorithm for adaptive data collection
we're actually working on some very
interesting things using the AIS for
example because the area's lets us know
where other objects near us right so if
we have a lot of AIS targets maybe we'll
also start the priority queue and this
is what you get you get kind of a
product that says the most important
data will the queue on connectivity this
is a pair the first object they change a
lot maybe near ports and the least
important parts of the voyage the
background what you saw the the sea and
sky they are in queueing at the end what
does this do so you have short
connectivity windows but remember you
have very long digestion time onboard
the ship right four days strong GPU why
not take advantage of crunching all
these numbers to just get the most
meaningful data first so this is what
you actually get after maybe
implementing this algorithm you get some
I yeah we put a thermal camera as well
because it's very good against fog haze
and opens your eyes at night our next
system will have three thermal cameras
yay yeah so start collecting data and
you can see some very interesting edge
cases right so visibility conditions
near ports all of a sudden you're seeing
a lot of interesting things but this is
still painful
lo are there any shortcuts can we do
something faster yes we can play video
games right so simulators are actually
quite a good way of collecting data
right if it's good enough for us
what is it good enough for the computer
for the algorithm right so playing
simulators using scripts that actually
change the environment change the
weather change the time of day change
everything
plant different objects with the
respective bounding boxes for the
algorithm to say hey this is a sailing
vessel this is also a sailing vessel
this is also this is maybe a tanker I
don't know but using this kind of of of
say groundbreaking technology even
though it's not that much but it
actually allows and enriches your data
set to a lot of edge cases which is very
good for us um it even allows us to
generate some harsh weather conditions
like fog and maybe near shore and it's
still working
progress but it's scalable and it can be
used on the fly while training in the
millions which is pretty awesome a lot
of examples all right so one almost last
issue about using and putting a
high-tech deep learning black box on a
ship is the reliability issue like I
told before no one will let you put your
black box that I don't know why it
turned right on a huge ship you need to
build something really reliable and this
is actually the challenge that Orca is
facing every day the challenge is first
of all how to build a system that could
aid commercial ships that are shipping
millions of dollars per voyage in the
most reliable way possible first of all
when I talk about reliability let's talk
about yeah the software needs to work it
cannot crash cannot have any lags
needs to be sustainable is to be great
what does it mean it means that you need
to be able to remote update your system
this is a challenge and the second
challenge is actually detecting
everything you cannot afford miss
detections and false alarms and I don't
know what birds all over the place yes
this is a ship no this is bad we cannot
afford that
so I'll talk about these two topics and
like I mentioned before the challenge
here is introducing the old-fashioned
maritime industry with new technology
about reliability again a little bit
it's not code it's more of an
architecture so yeah a state-of-the-art
docker containers we actually build our
entire system using the micro services
architecture well each of our modules of
our sub modules is actually very
reliable I would say black box and it's
interchangeable what does it mean
tomorrow and you detect all algorithms
comes out to the market no problem are
contained environment is written in any
language you want
it could be C C++ it could be Python
could be chaos pi torch whatever we can
just interchange it with ease second of
all it's very easy to monitor we can
know we can we can tell if the for
example the a communication engine fell
fell down oh [ __ ] I need to raise it up
I need to fix I need to provide a hotfix
and and on fail and this is the most
important aspect the entire stack
doesn't crash I mean the system still
runs you still can use the system you
still collect data but maybe you don't
see any other ships in another case
maybe you see the ships you still can
collect data but you're not I don't know
analysis the analysis perform visual
analysis on the image I know so the idea
is Michael services and everything is
actually stored on sts-3 and AWS more
about reliability so we this is actually
footage from our own MongoDB we follow
the ship
if windward is doing it in the macro
global level we're actually doing it in
the micro chip level
so maybe collaboration over there big
company yeah we are also monitoring how
many nautical miles the ship has sailed
is this the communication everything we
want and we can never forget the human
in the loop we need to allow the humans
they are bad people
you need to allow them and involve them
in the development process because we
need to introduce how our technology
works so they can actually see with
their own eyes even though maybe one day
autonomous ships will not have anyone at
all so you don't even even need screens
but until we get there take a lot of
time we need to introduce them hey
captain this is a ship is this correct
use the captain's as validation for our
data why not it doesn't know how it
works so what's next for the for
incoming future for all kai
of course mo installation on more ships
we need more data by the end of the
month we're going to be installing on a
second ship Tamara is resisting it
because it stops at Turkey and he
doesn't want to go out the port Turkey
he's afraid of the Turkish and we're
actually building the most meaningful
data sets of the marine domain of the
visual domain which is something that's
not a thing yet we're talking about
sensor fusion so cameras 2a is cameras
to radar already working and building
that we talked about a little bit car to
car predictive maintenance the guise of
a wind were talked about ship to vac
interesting and ship to ship I'm talking
about the true interconnected ship to
ship sharing of information of
interesting information for example one
ship saw a human in distress but it
couldn't stop so it shares these data
with maybe other ships it's so a
container it's saw an iceberg something
it doesn't even have a is data right now
son we're gonna work hard relentlessly
on alerts based on semantic
understanding of the scene what do I
mean by that it's not enough just to
understand that I am near a port there
is a vessel over there I'm gonna be
stumbling a ship in a couple of minutes
we actually want to create a context
database which means hey captain it's
dark outside the visibility is low
you're entering Singapore and you have
50 vessel in front of you we recommend
that you slow down a bit this is the
idea of the contextual database so these
are actually the alerts and navigation
recommendations kind of a co-pilot if
you'd like and last but not least the
autonomous ships challenge which is not
only about autonomous navigation it's
also about predictive maintenance it's
also about remote control remote
monitoring what happens if you have
pirates along the way what happened what
happens if the I'd know it founders
struck the ship and all the system
collapses so autonomous ships probably
are coming but it will take a couple of
years to get there so we are building
the building block the actually platform
for the brain is the idea thank you guys
let's catch up I'm over here I have my
lot of yeah you call this card is still
a thing right yeah this one I have a lot
of these and we're looking for great
engineers software engineers algorithm
engineers system engineers and let's get
up let's catch up and we are here to
stay so I hopefully will do some great
things
thank you Anand from the dock for coming
here the docker actually some of our
investors and we're looking forward in
the shift in the maritime domain
especially in Israel we have a lot of
great assets here a lot of great people
and I think we're gonna grow and do some
really amazing things thank you very
much yes
hi-yah so it's an ongoing effort so what
she asks is are we on men tating the
synthetic data with the real data and
trying to figure out the best mixture
say yeah of course this is one of the
first efforts that we put so the entire
paradigm of simulators is that it will
get you to a certain point of capability
and from there you need to complete it
using a real data so because we started
by building the data collection platform
and while we'll add it we're actually
involving the synthetic data it's now a
matter of research and R&D we have only
just one algorithm engineers and is the
engineering is doing a lot of things so
finding the correct mixture of what data
what model what hyper parameters this is
a work of art and it will get
[Music]
communication collisions you might want
to send information about the shape of
this of the shape the size of the yeah
that's correct and that's that's
interesting and that's a given free
using the great AIS which actually gives
you the type of vessel usually the size
the length the birth everything you need
to know it's a work in progress ship to
ship will will happen when we have
installed our system on more ships it
happens today using rate radio
frequencies communications but the idea
is maybe generating a true network of
interconnected ships that collaborate
can work together yeah it's a great idea
thank you so much
yes so good question actually one of the
girls there to transfer learning with
respect to simulated big data - how good
is in general not necessarily the domain
and the other thing is with regard to
the priority of the data I would think
of it that you don't want only the first
before this law but you won't find a
mixture which wait more about the past
and take also for the flow otherwise you
might have missed all this slow moving
you want to learn anything snow yeah so
learning something slow is super
important what I showed you here is just
a partial solution of our algorithm just
to give you the concept of not
collecting everything because it's not
meaningful but thank you for that and
for the augmentations of the synthetic
data so it's a hard question to answer
because our systems are actually
learning the contours the shape the
colors all of these in the deep learning
algorithm but we cannot know for sure
how much it improve so if you try to
train only on synthetic data you get
mediocre results on our own benchmark
which is consist of true images
collected from from the ship in a more
generalized environment in harsh weather
conditions different visibilities which
is pretty hard and just training using
our own collected data is also getting
us not such a high score because you
need more more samples and we're just
collecting the samples now it will take
us time we thought about using Gans to
transform simulated data into real
looking data and also for super
resolution which is also pretty awesome
but thank you and I'm out of time so
thank you very much again
[Applause]